[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits I'm link and I'm
Rhett this week at the round table of
dim lighting we are exploring the
question is Thanksgiving better without
family Oh what go really or is it better
with family because it's kind of like a
science experiment we got a we've got a
control group over in an experimental
group because I went home to visit my
family I haven't told you much about it
so we're gonna catch up and you stayed
behind and I haven't told you much about
you haven't told me much about it so I
want to I want to figure this out this
is a legitimate legitimate question
first time ever that I went home for
Thanksgiving actually so I guess
previous years are an in-form I can
experiment with in my own family of
being with them or not as I think out is
a good point
yeah there were there was some strategy
to went into it and now on the backside
of it stress let's discuss let's let's
let's figure that out let's see let's
see what social science has to say not
really let's just see what we have to
say and before we get into that I had an
experience that I wanted to tell you
about all right as you as you know you
are a massage aficionado yeah I and in
my next life I'm gonna be or in
retirement I guess or tomorrow if I
really get fed up with this place I'm
gonna I'm gonna be a massage critic all
right I'm gonna go in first ever like a
restaurant critic I'm gonna roll into
places you have a blog and I'm gonna I'm
gonna have like a like oh like a well
written assessment very detailed about
the massage massage expert blog spot.com
you might think that that will link that
Yelp and you might be right but you
would be wrong because I don't get paid
to write on Yelp and I would get paid to
do this right yeah it's a booming
business waiting to happen so yeah I I
find facing myself very into massage
well receiving and and I you know
interestingly
I think I'm just as much his massage
expert not blocks out a copy it is a
website of course it is link you got to
buy it from that it's my website the
site where you can find anything about
massage exclamation point
no hasn't been updated since when 2009
okay all right I think and get in for a
low low price
I enjoy massage as well I think sure to
say I enjoy massage as much as you but I
have not been as aggressive and
scheduling my own massages
I enjoy massage so much that two years
ago when my in-laws asked my wife what
can we get what can you get for the guy
who has everything what can you get for
the guy who has a putting green at his
house what can you give her the douche
okay what can we get for your for your
douchebag husband now that's two years
ago you didn't have a putting green at
night yeah yeah but you were a douche a
man Jesse said you know what be really
by the way I don't want to ever use that
word again
I don't like it you don't want to say
douche I think it's wrong on a on a
bunch of lovely the word douche is
something you don't want to say can we
can we come up with another word cuz
this is a running gag but I just want to
use a different word what douche
backwards I'm uncomfortable with it
should it what is douche backwards kid I
gotta write it down look look how
douchey this is I I realized that I had
so much merch on and then I realized if
I did this I gotta actually write this a
quad ech ech ech you'd e8c uod Hey look
at this a cured a cured what if I what
if I seriously did this now for those of
you just listening I I've rolled my
sleeves up and I got my hat on backwards
for those of you listening you've made a
great choice I think is well right all
right do not watch the video a neck wad
I mean wow this is this in fact keep
going with your store no I would like
people to take a screenshot of this and
then put a quad underneath it
don't put me in the screenshot well
actually I'm doing it in my I'm doing
into my camera oh yeah I got me I got
one into my camera anything I wanted to
the goodbye camera you can't get out of
that one so you're your in-laws ask
Jessie
what could they give you and apparently
you said a gift certificate for massage
or do you want your in-laws to give you
a massage like both of them well that
was my first request
I wanted a for hander for that's what
they call that no they don't
it is massage from two people who is
called a four hand massage I think
that's all being a monarch no four
handed I know it sounds like some weird
thing you'd find on urban dictionary but
that's I literally seen no don't don't
lie to my face with that hat anyway I am
good idea though I require that it cost
over twice as much money I requested a I
said I wonder if I'm thanks for letting
me yeah I just feel like we're honest
can you call massage place like spot not
go can you call a massage place and say
I would like a deep tissue massage for
90 minutes and I want to people can you
do that yeah they say it's double the
price
maybe they say it's you know maybe it's
you know 1.5 the price I don't know
let's find out make a call you guys be
that could be your first blog the guess
what happened when I called and asked
for a four hander yeah I'm gonna do it
alright I'm gonna do it so anyway Jesse
said he likes massage and what that
turned into is them getting me gift
certificates to several massage places
and of course not being from here
several massage place they did not
necessarily calculate the distance you
know from where I'm at in town okay yeah
and where these massage places were and
it would require a special trip
basically and so I haven't gotten I have
seven died had done it but when you went
home for Thanksgiving you went home on a
Sunday or Monday or something and so I
was here Sunday and
I would like would like you to know I
did work I did work as much as my wife
would let me it's trying to get ahead
man
but the first day of make one of us of
Thanksgiving vacation I was like you
know what I need the red stirrer need
some me time and the wrestler needs to
go across town and you know one of these
muscles were putting into practice our
last conversation which I've thought a
lot about by the way and so I go to this
Thai massage place on the island on the
west side no it's just on the west side
and it was so I I would not have been
able to tell you exactly what Thai
massage was even though now I realize
I've had one before now that I've gone
back and like oh so now I understand so
I went to this place that was I just
really I mean I'm really cool like so
like I was it was kind of just in the
not a strip mall but it was just in on
an office block in Santa Monica but when
you when you walked in it was just like
oh I'm been transferred Pennsylvania
transported into this rainforest cafe
really didn't Disneyland
yeah but the woman said put this t-shirt
and these pants on and they were Thai
fisherman pants and she was like do you
know how to put those on it's like yeah
buddy yeah I do I got a pair of home how
googled that and I've watched the
YouTube video how to do that so yes I
know how to do it and I was like oh this
is interesting because I was planning on
getting naked underwear underneath the
Thai dance yeah no no I know because
I've got pants on
all right and then I go back out into
the area you don't wear them must know
that you don't take them off you leave
them on the whole time
oh that's why I'm getting it too is the
massage area is basically communal so
not massage tables but massage pads no
hole for your face so you're not face
down your face to the side or just face
in the pillow suffocating are these pads
on the floor like kindergartners taking
naps well they were yeah they were all
on the floor I mean it was like an
elevated deck area with a bunch of
curtains so that you could curtain off
the different places but there were
multiple massage
just going on and you basically can kind
of see and hear the other people who
were around you and you left all this on
and then the reason that the massage
happens on the floor is because this
woman proceeded to do a yoga routine on
my back in fact she may have just been
doing her yoga routine and may have had
nothing to do with massaging me at all
maybe it was just a scheduling conflict
and it was just a woman who showed up
for yoga and decided and just was on top
of me the whole time awesome so listen
I'm haunted by the way I think that
we've I think it was an early gmm
episode those don't matter we we I think
we both had and talked about massages
where women would stand on our backs and
hold on the bars on the ceiling yeah and
then walk on your back and give you a
massage with their full body weight
because the inside weighed like 80
pounds and so that that is that is Thai
massage but I technically the being on
the floor makes it authentic
oh and with the curtains did you say
that they pulled a curtain around so
that no one could see this happening or
was it a spectator sport for privacy
yeah they pulled it around okay so you
couldn't see anyone else getting walked
on right but I knew that it was
happening I just it was like I know it
was like an operating room but the thing
that was notable about this was with
curtains it was the most painful massage
I have ever received no I've had I've
had some painful massages I usually tell
people go as hard as you possibly can
I'll let you know if you need to let up
oh yeah and never before have I told
somebody to let up I mean I just taking
it me neither you know but this woman
was poking and prodding me with her full
body weight and it would it would get to
a place where it was like all the way I
could have sworn she was balancing on an
elbow it's how it felt
unlike your mid-back she would be the
mid-back the low back that she put the
shoulders now first of all there was all
this stuff happening and I was going and
she would she would really dig in now
ago
and that would be like that would be
like the first signal that like this is
painful was that did you do that
consciously or did it eke out as she's
pressed on you
it started in involuntarily and then it
became like a code a language so you
know everyone can hear that through the
cheat I didn't care it hurts so bad I
couldn't stop Wow but here's the thing
after a few times of going mmm
I was like hold on did it does that
sound like I'm enjoying it I can't
answer that and the answer is yes and
then my follow-up statement is I don't
want to hear it again okay well you're
gonna hear more than that because I
gotta keep going I gotta tell you the
whole name you were thinking I gotta
teach you the language fitted the
language so after about ten minutes are
going I realized that she may think that
I'm digging this
but you weren't she was digging me man
she was digging into me I mean and I
knew that it was helping you know what
I'm saying like she would get on a knot
I could feel her on a knot yeah yeah
she's working that night of money you
got to work that night you got to work
my booty not she didn't really work the
booty nut she just worked the muscle
nuts I love the way you worked my moody
night and I'm tight there was why I'm so
straight there was one time when she was
so into the shoulders need someone to
work much yeah then I was like I'm gonna
have to change the language up and at
that point I was just like oh oh oh I
was like I got to move beyond mmm and I
got to go Oh what about how about just
wait no now oh yeah cuz I was like I can
I thought that then well now too far
that's direct him then the way I mean it
seemed no man it was on the shoulder
okay the next part was gonna be stopped
I didn't wanna say that
stop oh and then and then at that point
she was like is this hurting you and I
was like yeah a little bit yeah like yes
I feel like I'm about to die I didn't
say that
now you had given her the speech go go
for it now let you know if it's too much
no no I because I saw what was happening
I was like this is gonna be painful and
you didn't say anything let me tell you
by the time this was over she had done a
couple of things where she does one
thing where she sat on my shoulders like
I was about to like take her on a
piggyback ride she's like okay now stand
up get out of here I gotta read
something on the top shell am I supposed
to back room is she gonna say get up I'm
just supposed to go but what she was
doing it's like Yoda with Luke Skywalker
man she was sitting on top of me and
compared I was in I was sitting with my
legs crossed in front of me and then she
sat on my back and folded me know and I
was like and I you know I'm just so
prideful
I'm just so prideful I can't tell people
that that shouldn't happen to me you
know and so and so she folds me in half
and then she's like you're so flexible
and I'm not really I'm just too prideful
to say that you are breaking me in half
like I'm going to have to go to a doctor
thankfully my back is in very good shape
now compared to that I mean especially
with your back I'm surprised but first
of all my back is in great shape so I
actually feel that I mean oh no you know
no I would have stopped her if I really
thought that something was gonna happen
my back I I'd you were saying cross
applesauce I am flush you put your nose
into the mat yeah and but I am flexible
I'm very flex your foot okay in your
prideful and you're doing oh yeah I've
been told by many people now so flexible
my physical my personal trainer you know
you sound like right did deep so
flexible many people tell me how
flexible I am no well that's not likely
I'm the humblest person I know I'm just
saying that like I'm proud of myself in
the flexibility I've gained you know
done it for the sake of my back and it
actually has been very helpful for my
life and for my Thai massage experiences
so I don't have to stay here whoa did
you don't ride me like a horse so but
when when you said am i when she said am
i hurting you you said yes I said you
could go a little easier you made it
about her yeah and then and then she
said you're not doing it right and then
she said don't die don't die yeah she'd
said that but she's gotta be funny
anyway I feel like I'm not a tip I found
incredible coming out of there and I
felt like I don't know if I can do this
again because I do think I was
preoccupied with being injured the whole
time was it a high it sounds like a
high-end place yeah yeah it was it was
very high-end yeah yeah well Mona it
wasn't one of these strip mall locations
it the cops might show up at any point
it wasn't one of those yeah it was this
is legit man this is legit I got a tea
after I got done and everything I've had
tea most people that I'm tempted to go
there cuz that sounds like a good well
there's well me you said yeah well you
can be a guest blogger on my site guest
post from red MC no you can have audio
files of my of my length my massage
language proven proven to work proven to
work at one time whoa whoa oh goodness
that's it man that's my massage thanks
for asking snapped you in half so we're
gonna talk about Thanksgiving travels
and experiences but first I do want to
let you know that you know I kind of
feel self-conscious about how much merch
I have on right now I've never I don't
believe I've ever done the Hat and the
shirt together you know I feel like a
paul brother it's happening though you
got yourself a good mythical hat
available at mythical dot store yep no
that's not even available to me so I
sold out we've moved on to new hats
check them out this shirt here is
available at mythical dot store is that
available oh yeah but this is not this
sold out this is sold out you see there
was one with a pot
man yeah boil for safety you got to get
it while it gets good milk at that store
got to keep him guessing support
entertainment she wanted an
entertainment and rep rep your boys
mething about star rep your boys I like
that I decided well it was a long
actually many years went into when is
the the the Christmas that we're not
gonna go home but we're gonna stay here
in Los Angeles and celebrate as just an
immediate family every single year I
guess for six years well I try eight
really yeah this Christmas will be eight
years in Los Angeles for us this
Christmas would be the night Wow
because your first one was in 2011 right
and so if you get out the one and they
ate no so this year would be yeah this
year would be the ninth okay I'll take
your word for it cuz it's my brains kind
of hurting right no I think it's no this
year would be the eighth this year would
be the eighth
it's all right in the 2007 previous
years we go home we'd stay here for
Thanksgiving or go on vacation that was
that because summers were so crazy we
would take vacations every Thanksgiving
we both would we both would
and then for Christmas time leading up
to the new year we go home for the past
seven years but I don't know you kind of
you kind of want to experiment and say
what it you know you don't have your own
thing okay you with your immediate
family like before we moved we were
starting to do the thing where
grandparents and and aunts and uncles or
siblings would come visit us and we'd
have our own thing in our own traditions
and then people would show up at
different times and we'd still go to
places on Christmas night or Christmas
Eve that type of stuff but like we had
special Christmas morning that was a
special time for us very special insert
whatever special holiday time for you
and your family is appropriate if if
it's a different set of holiday it's
still all applicable I believe
I just want to include you all but but
my point is once we moved out here we
didn't have any of that because like the
the week leading up to Christmas and all
the way afterward it was just we were
itinerant and I've talked about this I'm
sure on the podcast many times as we've
called each other up but we decided okay
this is the year we're gonna we're gonna
stay here but we'll go home for
Thanksgiving instead and it'll be a
little early and then what will help
we'll talk it over with family members
you know some have a more developed
opinion than others and you know you got
to talk to him in certain orders and get
everybody's buy-in but everybody was
very gracious and it turns out they were
even thinking yeah I think this would be
good for for for you guys you know your
kids are getting older you need to have
your own traditions and your own things
that you want to do so I was very
relieved that all of our family was on
board so you think this is the new
normal I think it can go either way now
but I at this point I'm I mean we'll
have an experience Christmas here so I
don't know if it goes as well as I have
like super high Oh Christmas here may
suck it may suck I don't know but people
say it's a ghost town here in Los
Angeles it's like it transforms into a
different city where no one's here and
like I'm pretty interested in that that
would be cool
and I have the run of the city yeah
let's have the run of the city just like
take Christmas trees everywhere just
like loot like go looting with my family
that's what I do that's good take take
empty stockings and fill them with
people's valuables yeah that's a fun
Christmas tradition sorry I don't know
the jury's still out but I'm saying that
that's the possibility that it may be
the new normal when you're talking about
traditions like that people can come
visit us and be able and be included in
it we're not being exclusive but anyway
it felt really good for for people to be
supportive and so we went home for
Thanksgiving as part of that and we
stayed it
Christie's sister's house where we
that's that's our home base now and my
nephew Nia my he's 3 years old and he's
wide open it was it was it was great to
be there and hang out with him and the
kids just you know hanging out with him
but he got this he wanted to perform
these songs he has original songs well
so everyone would be sitting around he
would get up in front of everybody and
he would he would make Lincoln Orlando
play the drums he'd be like okay play
really hard like play really and he
would get he'd get angry be like he
would like channel anger as a way to say
how hard he wanted the drums to be
played I like this good on like a basket
but like three play harder and he would
grab the hands that are holding the
sticks and he would say play really hard
and then what you got it to like large
not Lars Ulrich but what's the drummer
for Metallica
I brought the drummer for John Cougar
Mellencamp Kenny Aronoff what about John
Bonham I mean once once he got Lincoln
to full John Bonham like did breaking
breaking breaking sticks then he starts
singing and he's like Britney kept
having to encourage him now remember
we're gonna use a singing voice not a
yelling voice I like this kid oh wow
okay I love him scream I like already
and he's like he just launches into we
make the rules we make the rules we made
the rule
fools and it turns out this is the
collaboration with another cousin of his
that wasn't present at the time so that
was the way we I was he and his other
cousin they it's very insightful you
know it gives lots of insight into the
psyche of a three-year-old right there
is a song this boy released there is a
song in which they've created a world in
which they make the rules they're yeah
they're in charge we make the rules
because the world is of all about rules
when you're three yes it's all about
rules in sight you know what we're gonna
make it okay
ultimately you realize that he captured
basically the spirit of rock and roll
song yeah I mean is that know if if we
make the rules
if rock and roll were acapella except
for your older cousin playing drums on a
wicker basket then yes I'm saying it's
like intense rock that is the underlying
message of all rock not the sound right
maybe in the voice like the screaming
kid even work you don't even have to
tell him not to scream and then there
was another one that I don't remember
the tune but it was basically something
like anything we can do we could do the
same I like the concept yeah and I don't
remember the exact words it's basically
like that we can do anything that we can
do and we're gonna do it kind of a
tautology you know why because if you
flip the record over we make the rules
and you were cheering it was fabulous
yes make the rules Nehemiah do that your
wife actually or your wife I don't know
somebody in your family did post this on
Instagram their Instagram so I did I had
to say that I have seen the ponies I've
been singing it all week yeah can't get
it out of my head we make the rules I
mean it's kind of like that anything you
can dream you can do that Lando
performed at his school that one of the
guys one of the parents wrote and then I
was like that's not true Lando remember
yeah totally
brokest shattered his dreams but I might
but you know what you make some rules
you couldn't hear my can make your own
rules the day before Thanksgiving we
went to my Nana's house
my dad's mom's house and you know I'm
not gonna get too sad but I will say
that it was it was it was difficult in
in in one way particular because it was
the first time Papa wasn't there you
know having passed away months ago and
with my Uncle Dan also passing away
right before that which I've talked
about on the show so it's like there was
a scientist
empty seats so to speak now I don't it
was it was never a plan to leave seats
empty but actually actually what
happened what had happened was after our
concert I've told you this right we we
went to well at-at our concert at the
North Carolina State Fair my mom and
Lewis Road there with my dad and Nancy
so this is your parents and their new
partners hanging out together yeah and
Nana all wrote in dad's truck up there
because they were concerned about
parking but it has been 30 years or more
more than that since your parents were
two a couple so it's it's oh yeah it's
we've had a lot of time for the for the
awkwardness to settle a little bit well
but it still usually I've never ridden
in a sink car anywhere right right right
right and so when when dad and Nancy
offered to take them I was like okay
I'll let them know and then like they
did it and it went great and then come
to find out on the ride there the ride
back they're talking about Thanksgiving
plans and how we're coming into town for
Thanksgiving that Christmas it's time
and they're like you know what dad and
aunt C were like sue you and Lois should
come to our Thanksgiving and I'm hearing
about this and I'm like after they had
decided they were like well we were
invited I was like oh it's I was like
sounds weird but awesome great oh yeah
so but hold on the first time ever my
mom came to my dad's side of to it to
like a big family event on my dad's side
of the family but I will say it cuz you
for even birthday parties growing up I
mean they we're all separate I'd have
twice as many birthday parties right
many Christmases what I'm getting at is
and you know this is you know super
common in our in modern society for
families to split up and there'd be two
entities and then the children have to
kind of make choices and go from place
to place
right it is pretty novel concept if you
can all get along I mean get together it
sounds like a movie which probably is
yes Christmas Eve we'd always go to
nanny's house my mom's mom my dad so
family I'd have nothing to do with it
because Christmas night was Nana's night
for my dad side of the family my mom had
nothing to do with that
I was the only one that would do both
and it was great because I got you know
you're not getting a lot more presents I
think yeah definitely um but now I don't
really get much presents and this is
Thanksgiving so presents are out of the
equation
Oh your family doesn't do Thanksgiving
prison so no they don't we don't we're
not even thankful oh she's kidding so we
don't even do thing it was it was this
interesting dynamic and there's like I
mean there's I think there were what was
the number ended up being like 16 people
there so it wasn't like an awkwardly
small group of people sitting around a
small table still a veritable putting a
bunch of tables together it was it
turned out to be you know it was there
were still moments of it being very sad
you know it's like really experiencing
missing these key members of our family
for the first time so I'm it it it in no
way erases that but it created something
new I mean my cousin Kurt and they had
an they had a newborn you know three
months old first time we met the baby it
was like this so there's all this
excitement that like gives and give
something to celebrate you know which
was very much needed and it's like and
then
look down at that end at a table and
it's like my mom's sitting there it's
like so weird but like this is great I
mean I think everybody's having a good
time and you know everybody did have a
good time it all worked out and at one
point you know I've talked about Lois my
my stepdad who I'll never call my
stepdad because that's just weird cuz he
got they got married way after I got
married but I'm like his catchphrase
good good good
talk about that right yes we talked
about it we build it up but the kids
relay all right Papa Luis is gonna be at
the Thanksgiving dinner tonight
they're like tonight and man is I'm like
yes so let's do a drinking game kids
good good good
you take a shot of gravy that's a good
idea
and yeah I'm like silly you gotta listen
for it and then lo and behold the kids
get up from the table after like we're
all sitting there at the table after the
food after everybody's eating some
people start getting up there doing
stuff but most people still at the table
and then I Lewis is like oh boy that was
good my ears perk up ha ha ha and I look
over it I look across the table at
Christy's like pulling a cord Christie's
eyes met mine he was like oh yes and
then Christy I look each other and that
was like the best moment of Thanksgiving
and then I look around for the kids and
they're not at a table they didn't even
witness I think Lilly was at the table
she didn't hear it somehow and that was
the only good good good of the whole
you're kidding that's the only one he
did and it gave you like a warning shot
yeah I mean everybody could have
gathered around her in that ball I got
it I just wanted the kids to get it I
mean the next day which was Thanksgiving
Day we're at nanny's house so my mom
said family my dad and Nancy weren't
invited to that I don't know it didn't
go both ways I don't know what happened
interested and we're there and Lois
didn't give a good good there it was
good good bad bad bad Thanksgiving well
after it was great Thanksgiving was
great there it was like nanny and her
siblings
Jimmy was there never seen Uncle Jimmy
yeah he was there he's hard he's hard to
understand yeah I love the way he talks
it's just I'm just saying it needs to be
subtitled yeah it needs to be he's like
he's have his own subtitle around his
neck he's have an iPad where's the
subtitle I'm not gonna do an
impersonation because I don't I think
that would be cruel but it's it I love
him for it this is you gotta that's the
thing about getting together of a family
is just yeah I'm in more observation
mode you know it's not like we're
getting into deep conversations or
anything we're just sitting around nanny
gets so cold that she set that literally
it was like 85 degrees tropical and so
like sir after we've eaten and it's 85
degrees and you're sitting shoulder to
shoulder in this like carpeted living
room with like the kerosene heater on
like everybody just started wilting man
and then a couple of family members
would have to go outside to smoke and
then they'd come back in and like me and
Christie are really sensitive to the
smell of smoke and like we got headaches
from just the residual smell on the
clothes and we started to really have a
difficult time so we had to I was like
well mom and Luis had to go to Louis's
family's thing and then we were gonna
stay like two more hours I'm like after
another hour and the dog shows over and
stuff I'm like the dog show we were
wilting we had to like get out of there
so I'm like well and we had seen nanny
another day before so we got some good
quality time and then I was like we said
our good-byes and headed out and then we
get out to the car and Chris is like
well we can't go back to Britney's
because they're not there they're at
JB's family's house and we don't have a
key so that we don't have somewhere to
be for like two and a half hours I'm
like well I really need a coffee and
it's Thanksgiving Day and we're driving
around to McDonald's and then I get into
McDonald's I'm a yes and then the
daggone McDonald's is closed
oh because you're in and I look across
it I look across I'm a danger and then I
look across the street and there's a
they got like a gas - I can't get gas
station
and then we drive to Fuquay I'm like
there's a McDonald's in Fuquay there's a
Starbucks in Fuquay I go to both of
those
they're both closed I'm getting
desperate I go to the Dunkin Donuts
closed I'm starting to feel like a real
loser now you're driving my family
around on Thanksgiving Day just feigning
for coffee and and getting turned away
like lame is well okay that's a little
man okay I don't remember this story
lame is I didn't watch the movie oh it's
exactly like that
Chrissy's like there's a sheets on my
gas station coffee oh you know what she
you know what I have never been in a
sheets I've never been inside a what
I've heard about him you order food from
the gas people can order you can order
lattes from a screen inside which I did
of course you did and that explains why
on Christmas Day me and my immediate
family were playing cards for an hour
and a half in a sheets gas station
because we had no where to be that's why
we got a group text of what you were you
playing cards and a gas station on
Thanksgiving and you know I felt kind of
defeated I'm like is this a father fail
does this speak does this does this
answer the question at the top of the
show that like it's better to not be
with family on Thanksgiving because here
I am choosing to play cards just with my
kids and my wife in a Sheetz gas station
and then Chrissy's like you know what
this could be a tradition oh gosh and
it's a magical phrase no matter what
happens if it's bad try this next time
you're in like a a weird defeated or odd
holiday situation just don't even think
about it just say it out loud speaking
into the ether this could be a tradition
everything changed at that moment like I
got a tingle on my spine I'm like you
know I sheets tingle
I got a sheets tingle I'm like yeah we
can
even if we're not here for Thanksgiving
we can fly all the way here to go to
this sheets it's like no we didn't mean
that but it changed the perspective on
the whole thing on a sponsorship from
sheets would definitely okay yeah work
it change this work it change it so that
that was my Thanksgiving and by the way
then I left there and we met Britain in
his family at a Waffle House so I went
from a sheets and then spent the next
two and a half hours at a Waffle House
on Thanksgiving nice upgrade both places
are great but Waffle House that's prime
I walked in we walked in the Waffle
House and I the manager looked at us and
he said out loud basically at the top of
his voice it what the hell and I thought
it was like yeah Thanksgiving night I
know we're here at a Waffle House of
course so are you manager it's great
that you're here so that I can be here
and then it turned out at the end he was
a fan but he didn't tell me that until
that was his reaction two and a half
hours later
so yeah gas station and Waffle House on
Thanksgiving night it can be a tradition
that's that's my update brother okay
well I had a different a different
different experience pretty much same
backstory been going home for Christmas
every year yep but all of a sudden we
can't go home for either Thanksgiving or
Christmas because of my son's basketball
commitments which just means we're gonna
get the LA Christmas as well but we also
got to LA Thanksgiving they've got
family coming out for Christmas so
taking care of that but after having
been you know we've traveled for the as
a family for the past few Thanksgivings
and so this was sort of the first like
for it well we've done we did like the
friendsgiving thing years ago but right
this was kind of a new a new group of
people and people who invited us were
very close to and but then they kind of
invited a lot of people that they know
that they're close to so there was
people that I had seen like once and
there was people I'd never seen you know
like 25 people
at this friendsgiving which is big in LA
yeah cuz you've got all these people who
don't go back home and nobody is with
their extended family and so you don't
want to find yourself alone in the
sheets and you got a lot of you got a
lot of single people you got a lot of
young couples without children and so I
think between oh me and my kids and then
one of their family and their kids were
the only like families with kids and
everybody else was you know younger
that's not more vibrant saw a picture of
the group sharp-looking group big group
I'd say there was 24 people you know 25
25 people yeah yeah you dressed up a
little bit for it I did I thought that
you did it looked like you were wearing
a sweater I had a sweater on
yeah I have my Thanksgiving sweater on
may not turkey feathers close enough you
could have seen that I have to zoom in I
don't my cranberry pants you couldn't
see that because because of the angle it
the pants were made out of like the
skins of cranberries the skin that hangs
off a turkey right there just bright red
wrinkly looks like leather unless you
get close turkey nutsack scrotum pants
but this cardem does hang from the chin
of a.com
so I was I was very excited because you
know me I love to eat and I was very
excited because a friend of the person
who's kind of throwing this was like
they're gonna take care of the food and
a few people did makes make things to
bring like my wife made a sweet potato
casserole
southern style with some pecans on top
brown sugar you know just just
traditional Thanksgiving side very good
and here's what I'll say I call that a
pre dessert not side note but anyway I
enjoyed the meal quite a bit you had you
had your staples and your turkey gravy
you cranberry sauce chutney whatever
and then like the sides of people had
brought but I did notice something you
know first of all there was obviously a
vegan option for basically everything
and this is Los Angeles so you got like
a vegan option for the turkey but it
wasn't like a tofu turkey the head like
seitan mm-hmm which I call Satan I just
go straight for that it's very big of
you to invite Satan to your Thanksgiving
celebration Satan steak we have to cut
him up and served him on Thanksgiving be
thankful for his death but the thing
that I kind of noticed is that the only
thing on my plate that had the
quantities of butter and sugar and flour
that I feel like constitutes
Thanksgiving yeah was what my wife
brought and I gotta say I know that
that's just a southern boy coming to Los
Angeles
I specifically remember one of the first
pot Luck's we ever came to when we came
out here this the this it was quite the
eye-opening mouth shutting experience
yeah yeah it was like all these people
brought all these sides and this one
girl was like I I made this this is
Paula Deen's recipe and I'm like eating
it I'm like really because she's and
then as I'm eating it she's like and you
know what I used half the butter and
half the sugar that Paula called for and
it's still good and I'm thinking Paula
knows best bro she have you seen the
silhouette of that woman she knows how
much butter and sugar you're supposed to
put in things right right and there's
just a different mentality and you know
what it's probably a better mentality
it's probably a mentality that lives -
that leads to a longer healthier life
but when Thanksgiving on the cob was
once a you've decided to throw caution
to the wind
I could have unfurl the sails
I could have buttered injected directly
into my veins on Thanksgiving I would do
that oh that was the thing we could make
it it and so I got a so it because
dessert time happened and I was like oh
there's a pumpkin pie and then I they
had labeled everything and it was
pumpkin pie vegan
vegan and I was like hmm and there was
like chocolate pie raw vegan what and
then it was like some kind of bites
vegan and now you know how vegan people
normally feel alright and here and so
what I thought was I was just like I
just want to go to Ralph's right now
right now and just get a pumpkin pie
from rouse you know just get a
grocery-store pumpkin pie put some
whipped cream on top and then unbutton
my pants and enjoy myself you know so
that was an adjustment it was an
adjustment that I feel like I can be
ready for next year mmm just I think I'm
gonna bring my own butter and my own
sugar and I'm just gonna just a squeeze
squeeze squeeze I be like I be bad let's
squeegee a butter and then less like a
sugar shaker and I'm just like don't
mind me you know just to kind of get
things out to the standard bring stuff
and label it unapologetically on vegan
Yeah right that sounds like a good brand
yeah and then the tagline is make it a
tradition we sell it at Walmart don't
you know make millions commercialize my
holidays I can't help but commercialize
things I helped a lot of people man but
one shouldn't make a dime one
traditional thing that happened was is
the host said we're gonna go around and
we're gonna say what we're thankful for
it we're gonna do it because it's Los
Angeles you kinda have to say we're
gonna do the cliche thing and we're
gonna say what we're thankful for
mm-hmm and you know everybody was saying
kind of the traditional things you know
family and friends what was your gut
knee-jerk reaction to that announcement
well I can think of three what was my
gut knee-jerk reaction to have the
announcement of the assignment that this
this cliche thing was gonna well there's
always a slight increase in heart rate
yeah I think that every normal normal
person even somebody who don't speak for
people I'm asking for you don't
normalize your response you tell me what
yours
I'm curious well a slight increase in
heart rate okay and then normal most
people that would and then like okay I
got to say something that I sort of mix
his humor and heart and heart the right
way this is you know this is a branding
moment I don't exactly remember what I
said I was thankful for because they cuz
there was a second question that I do
remember everything that I said well you
don't you don't remember what you were
thinking no it was something about new
new friends and family and then I said
so I I made a joke it went over well
trust me but then the second thing that
happened while we were eating which I
found very interesting was there was a
guy there that was a life coach again of
course was he paid to be there if you
know if you get if you get 25 people
together in Los Angeles well none of
them will be a wise coach so if you
don't have one life coach per 25 people
in Los Angeles the entire city implodes
it's funny that the the cashier at
Sheetz was a life so did he have a tag
how did you know he was alive well a hat
if someone is a life coach or a vegan or
into CrossFit you know it yeah right you
know I'm saying you find out pretty
early in the rises right I I am he
stands on list of those things he stands
up and he says we're gonna all answer
this question and again I liked it
because I was intentional conversation
it was 25 people at a table and you're
kind of talking to the people around you
but then it's kind of putting everybody
on the spot even the kids letting kids
had to mic both of my kids had to stand
up in essence first time but it was the
traditional question of if you had a
superpower what would it be and what
would be your first mission
oh I actually haven't heard what will be
your first first mission was new to me
cuz that's kind of thing that a life
coach adds to it you understand right
because what's your favorite superpower
that's just normal folk what's your
first mission life coach business card
here you go
the heart rate goes up even more when
that happened yeah like now curveball
now now it's precious time to shine so I
said it was weed one guy requested he
said can we instead of going around can
we just do popcorn style can we just as
you know what you can use share just
like that's a good idea what why is that
a good idea he wanted he wanted to get
dibs because of invisibility the
inevitability of it coming to you and
you're just thinking about what you're
gonna say he had a reason it was good I
thought it was great at the moment but I
had actually had this exact discussion
with my wife the week before now we
talked about what our favorite
superpowers would be before we argued
about it at some point on the debate
Arama I think if you believe in freedom
you believe in flight invisibility is to
hide yourself from freedom like a
shameful naked mole-rat don't be
deceived flight is not heroic it is soft
absorbed showboating look at me
I'm air swimming I can't remember
anything that we do around here but I
know we've talked about superpowers and
I personally invisibility versus
invincibility was one of our first but
we didn't a disability versus flight and
then yeah we've always said that that
teleportation is the is the superpower
that I would choose because it
replicates technically can replicate
invisibility and flight for all
practical purposes I would are you
asking me now cuz I would choose being
able to double myself and be invisible
so I could creep on myself and not even
know it well interesting and disturbing
but I did not say that because that's
the can't answer I actually said what I
did given you don't eat canned ham I was
i Jesse and I were were with each other
eating something and I was eating some
bad food this is a dream you lost this
is the week before they okayed me to
answer to the superpower thing okay and
I said you know what if I can have a
superpower it would just be to turn
everything that is bad
for me to eat into things that are good
for me the whole thing would just flip
so it would be like you know fried
chicken processed meats and it would be
not only would it taste good but it
would make me feel the way that good
healthy food would feel and be you know
synthesized by your body so did you tell
them this and did that just incriminate
you and what you were the thoughts you
were consumed by what so I was like I'm
gonna go early because I want so I can
enjoy everyone's ass oh I like that so
people got up and said a couple of
things that were kind of fun kind of
interesting and I was like the third and
I said well I've actually been thinking
about this because Jesse and I were
talking about this last week and I said
that I would turn everything that's bad
for me into things that were good for me
and my first mission would be would be
to start eating and you know it's the
closer it was the you know I set it up I
landed the punchline sat down I got some
jokes
i sat down everything's great riding
high
then somebody turned the tables somebody
actually stood up and said I would have
the power to heal and I would heal the
world okay no I was like oh this is
where this is going I thought this was
fun party conversation next thing I know
people are standing up and they are know
so our friend Mike smartest guy we know
he actually gave a really hilarious yet
really like man this is a great answer
he stood up and said that he would have
the ability to manipulate matter not on
the atomic level therefore not to induce
a singularity but on the molecular level
and he would take all the carbon that is
loose in the atmosphere and send it to
the core of the earth to take care of
the global warming problem and he
explained this in a very scientific way
that was pretty awesome
and in that jet
as as the things went by people talk one
person said I would give the power of
empathy I would have the power of
empathy and I would be able to give it
to people just by having interaction
with them I would it
so my answer about just turning fried
chicken into something that was good for
me got more and more yeah you know you
know you're sort of shallow if you will
and as we proceeded but I really enjoyed
the conversation and then somebody did
say eventually somebody was like screw
it I and they went they went back into
fun okay fun levels of conversation but
but I wasn't with my family my I was
with my immediate family but we're
talking about his extended family when
we talk about Thanksgiving is
Thanksgiving better with family and you
know my mom like is sending me pictures
of first of all she's sending me
pictures of what the plate of food that
she has made looks like I'm my oh yes
right now properly all you can think
about proper amounts to talk about
neuringer structured sharing time and
yeah if I could have one superpower
before my mom would be here serving me
things but I am well I mean there's
there's something that can't be
replicated yeah there's a connection
that you have with your extended family
that can't be replicated there's also a
level of light ok now you're a little
bit tired of each other and you got to
you know go play cards at a gas station
but then on the opposite end of the
spectrum there's like I'm meeting new
people I'm answering this question that
a life coach has come up with and it's
probably making new neurons grow in my
brain or something so I don't know I
honestly can't tell you which one is is
a holistically a better experience I
think what you described sounds like
something that if you had told me that
was you know February 2nd in LA maybe
you could have been in that type of
circle oh but then we did karaoke
oh you did karaoke the life coach
brought in a karaoke machine well isn't
he a ball of yarn is that a thing you
just came up with because that sounds
like a good saying that's it's the
saying that cats say if they're in this
conversation oh you wouldn't know about
not interested he brought in a karaoke
machine and everyone ended up singing
karaoke including my own kids whoo Wow
together sing a Bruno Mars song and I
don't want to say which one it was
because he may question my oh my
parental
intuition but the problem is you parent
via into it I'd say what do you guys a
palm reader but no we had a great first
of all we were there from like 2 o'clock
to 11 o'clock I mean it's a long long
frickin time a lot longer than you had
it I probably would have ducked out of
that too once the karaoke machine came
out though you felt like he had to stay
hmm you know karaoke on Thanksgiving I
don't know I I think that I'm very
thankful that because I'm like well yeah
I we didn't go around and say what we're
thankful for
like no life coach stood up and like
gave some sort of assignment and I think
man maybe that should have been me maybe
I should have been the life coach yeah
well mm-hmm I regret that a little bit
cuz I mean we had good conversations
though you know and then there was the
good good I mean there were there were
lots of great things there was a baby
being passed around for the first time
there was all types you know family
coming back together it was a beautiful
thing like I wouldn't change any other
again even the gas station part which I
which is a highlight you know the whole
thing just embracing just even the parts
that feels stagnant like sitting on a
couch with all these people and just
watching the dog show on mute which is
the only way to watch it it's a
beautiful thing so
I don't know I think it's it's
especially when you when you live when
you don't live with them I I'm I'm gonna
I'm gonna come down on this I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna say you know that
they're both it could be either I'm
actually gonna come down on this and I'm
gonna come down on the side of with the
caveat of living away from family that
you don't you don't see it becomes that
much more important and I think it's
even if nothing changes or it even feels
like it doesn't meet your expectations
because somehow that's always still part
of it honestly going back home for the
holidays there's like this like because
you start judging everything and all the
conversations and because it's true it's
charged with okay this is what this is
the first this is the one of the few
times that we can all get together can't
we just make it very special with the
answer is not any not much more special
than if you live there but just seeing
them by definition it becomes more
special and I'm coming down on that side
that is better with family even if it's
miserable and again I didn't describe
misery but I'm saying even if it were
that I think it's I think it's better
because it's an institution it's a
family institutional what if you
incorporated I mean next year if this is
gonna be your thing what if next year
you don't have to say you're a life
coach but you come with a conversational
topic and a karaoke machine Aniki best
yeah I could do that it's like last year
sing karaoke we ended up playing that
beanBoozled game and I had like old
people eating dirt flavors jelly beans
it was beautiful good grass flavored
beans what did you sing was it a country
song nope
was it
let me just a tease yes and let me put
it this way what there are and be the
song before it was with somebody saying
Whitney Houston's I want to dance with
somebody and I leaned over to this
myself
and then I look what it done I leaned
over to the to the life-coach / DJ and I
said I want to keep the party going I
want to keep the dance party going 80s I
want to keep this vibe going and
something that I can sing something you
can sing that's not something that I've
sung with you but it wasn't a dance song
it's not the word dance is not in the
title but it is a yeah yeah you
definitely want to move when you hear it
is it Lionel song yes all night long
yes you sing all night long yes I did
Kumble eat a set D boy yeah man I hey
what you're supposed to say did you get
them to sing that everybody was
everybody like hey jumbo jumbo
well some people people who knew it I
had it I had to wait to potty
oh wait go when I had the words on the
iPhone and so no one else could see them
you know what I'm saying like the guy
handed me his phone oh the the karaoke
the the karaoke / life coach had a phone
and he was like giving it to you so you
were looking at the little house so I
couldn't I couldn't broadcast it it
wasn't being projected it wasn't that
level maybe next year so where are you
coming down on this question maybe I
took the safe road in terms of family
members but I think that's I think
that's where I'm at I feel like if
you're if you're isolating I think a
trip back home is a it encompasses more
than just the Thanksgiving experience
because you're hanging with and seeing
these people that you don't see on a
regular basis so I would say that if you
take a look at the whole Thanksgiving
holiday I think that ultimately I'd
rather see my family but I think that if
you just give me that isolated curated
because I feel like I had a curated
Thanksgiving experience and again there
was some there was some two healthy
options that I feel like colored that a
little bit but like I said I think I can
I can just take care of that
next year hey bring just get some
pumpkin pies from the grocery store
makes a big thing of mac and cheese
bring the sweet potatoes you know just
make sure there's enough high-calorie
stuff as an option so you're saying if
the your answers still about if the food
were just a little better then it would
have been perfect oh okay you know what
I'll take it back what about empathy and
carbon because the food because the food
is such a big part of Thanksgiving for
me I think I got to be with Mama on
Thanksgiving if I have to make a choice
you do well we know what we're doing
next year see it the sheets but and the
thing is is I'm I'm gonna have an L a as
long as Locke's playing basketball I'm
gonna have an L a Thanksgiving for the
next four years
so mama gonna have to come out here and
make some food for us hey jumbo jumbo
yeah well I gotta have the phone in I
haven't sung that song enough I didn't
actually sing it all night long went
done all right so let us know about your
experience
hash tag ear biscuits you do you love
your family I love my faster question I
do and then you ended up you ended up
watching that a tiger and Phil Goff
thing wasted my day doing that yeah I
was flying by was Friday I was flying
back a parent for it I would have 20
bucks I would have watched that I
watched it that's a good way to watch
golf it seems like I would have done
that I think the consensus was it was a
bit of a flop is what people thought
because they're both kind of old and at
least Phil considered a little
irrelevant now but he beat Tiger so give
me a freakin break Samuel Jackson was
involved Charles Barkley was there he's
always a he's always a ball yard so
anyway I highly I highly recommend it I
think they should do it again I'll watch
it again I'll waste half of my day
sitting there on the
ouch watching golf watching Tiger Woods
breathe heavily into his microphone
which was on at all times because it was
live streams yep I really had to get a
lot of refunds because the live stream
didn't work right or something
yeah they ended up making it free
halfway through but you'd already pay
bleacher report but I'd already paid you
know what you can keep on Lenny bleacher
report and you did a bold thing how did
that how did this become about that this
is just us talking to watch more ear
biscuits click on the playlist on the
right to watch the previous episode of
your biscuits click on the playlist to
the left and don't forget to click on
the circular icon to subscribe if you
prefer to listen to this podcast it's
available on all your favorite podcast
platforms thanks for being your mythical
best
[Music]